in the beginning of your filmmaking how
fearful or brave were you to ask for
more the beginning of our career ask for
more from money our subjects or money or
everything everything I know you had
talked about an interview confidence in
versus being afraid to ask for more
right and that really oh it's like a
light bulb went off because not even
gender-specific but just just the fear
of appearing to you know what if we
pushy it is generous is it okay okay
well but but it is gentle for that and I
think you talked about how you didn't
even realize that was a thing and you
just kept you were okay with asking for
more and I'd love to hear more about I
think I mean I think a lot of women
professional women have that kind of
trajectory which is you know as you have
more success and you have more personal
confidence you will ask for more and we
we were two women we own our own company
we have staff and we've noticed over the
years that the boy
our boy employees will always ask for
more even if they don't deserve it and
and the women won't so I think part of
it's just you know we also we we matured
and we got more confident but also we're
business owners and I think you start
seeing the world differently when you
are asking for money when you're taking
care of money when you have staff
working for you when you're a director
you're telling people what your vision
is and expecting them to they work for
you so all of the things that help
people get more confident and ask for
more we were put in a position that we
were able to grow in it so now that
we're almost 30
we're insanely confident we yeah I mean
we have approval it's privilege to make
documentary films it's a privilege to be
in this business and direct but there's
also a marketplace for the stories we
have to tell there is more of a
marketplace and there's ever been and so
I think a lot of filmmakers especially
earlier in their career just feels so
like
that anyone is interested in financing
their work or supporting their work and
I totally understand that but I think
it's really important to graduate into a
place where you realize that everyone
with is is moved by important stories
well told and it's very hard to tell a
story and important story well and so
there's a premium for those people they
can do it and it's important to realize
that especially as a woman director
because if you don't ask it will not be
offered to you so you have to know that
and to you know make demands that are
reasonable that are fair and so you
don't just end up you know working for
less or or feeling less than so we can't
we that cabin pretty early on in our
career I mean we put our heads down and
we work and we make a movie that's what
we do but we also know that this is
important work that that people want to
see and will and will pay for and that
sort of thing so it's really fine
finding that balance between doing
subjects that really interest us and
also realizing that it is a business as
well so then asking for more being given
somewhat access to footsteps I think
you'd said maybe that they'd let you
sort of be in the lobby for a little bit
it was like sort of baby steps with them
and I don't I mean that that was the
access that they gave us that was it
yes okay they they gave us the ability
to meet their clients that's what we
were asking them for we did not film
inside footsteps hardly ever except a
couple of one-on-one sessions which you
see in the movie right and they're
excellent by the way
oh thank you yeah those were hard-fought
scenes thank you those were hard to get
very very hard to get I can see why yeah
so we weren't at we weren't asking them
for more that's all we needed from them
so we were very persistent and patient
and you know gave them a good pitch of
why we were the right people for them to
trust and they did it and then we met
their members and we kept our end of the
bargain and we made a movie that they
like and they can use in any way they
want
so we
all we all got something out of it which
is another thing that you understand as
you get more seasoned that everyone is
doing something for their own incentive
and you have to figure out what that
incentive is and also in terms of asking
for more I mean they had been contacted
by other filmmakers multiple filmmakers
over the years and they had said no and
so we said but you haven't been
contacted by us and we have a body of
work to show so it's not abstract so
much they could see all of our past
films are five plus feature-length
documentaries plus a lot of their work
and they can judge for themselves you
know how big of a risk is this footsteps
took a big risk they had no editorial
control over the film they were not
invited for any editorial feedback and
so they had to trust that at least these
filmmakers didn't have a specific agenda
and would tell it like it is which is
all we can guarantee and so they've kind
of jumped off a cliff as well and you
know that's what it takes it's like it
takes really really brave individuals
that will trust you and organizations in
order for this documentary thing to even
happen we rely on on people to trust us
and rely on goodwill and we take it as a
big responsibility and as a big gift and
it can be a heavy burden because people
have trusted you and entrusted you with
their secrets and their stories and so
that has not gotten easier that is just
you know something that we grapple with
every time are we doing right by this
person is this do this person mean to
say that or is this the one day that
they would say such a crazy thing that
would be great in the movie but they
actually don't really mean it
so you have to sort of also suss out you
know what what is representative of a
person or an organization so so that we
had a lot of those sort of you know we
had to grapple with a lot of those sort
of rocky moments on this particular
movie
you